Samsung a présenté il y a pas longtemps
son nouveau smartphone dans l'entrée du
milieu de gamme c'est le A14 5G un
smartphone avec un grand écran de 6,6
pouces alors ici c'est pas du Super
AMOLED c'est du TFT alors ce que je vous
conseille de faire moi c'est de venir
dans le confort visuel que vous venez
activer vous venez casser un petit peu
la température de couleur ça sera
beaucoup plus agréable pour vos yeux ici
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement
vous laissez un adaptatif et lui fera le
taf viendra switcher automatiquement
c'est plutôt un smartphone qui s'adresse
au primo-occident c'est plus des parents
qui vont les acheter pour des enfants
pour leur premier smartphone et dans ce
cadre là il fera le taf et il le fera
plutôt pas mal vous avez à l'arrière
trois caméras on n'a pas de
stabilisation optique on a par contre
une très grosse batterie de 5000 maheur
on a ici un dos en plastique avec un
côté un peu granulaire on a ici 4 Go de
RAM et soit 64 Go de stockage soit 128
et c'est un smartphone qui est
disponible au tarif de 249 euros dans la
version bien évidemment 5G le Galaxy A14
5G fera le boulot dites-moi ce que vous
en pensez est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
un smartphone dans l'entrée de gamme
chez Samsung et est-ce que ce A14 5G
pourra vous faire de l'oeil marquez moi
ça bien évidemment dans les commentaires